foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday November 22nd I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
having hearing problems instead of using
hearing aids you might be able to get
away with just using airpods
that's according to a study published
last week in the journal eye science the
study found that a new pair of Apple
airpods Pro may help some people hear
almost as well as using traditional
hearing aids that could be good news for
anyone struggling with their hearing and
for Apple which has been working on
making inroads in the health space
joining us to discuss the study and its
limits is our Medical Science reporter
Dominique mossbergen hi Dominique thanks
for joining me hi Zoe how are you I
you know can you start by telling us
what came out of this study you know
what is it about airpods that make them
so useful for people struggling with
their hearing
so the study found that airpods Pro with
Apple's live listen function which is
this feature that allows you to use an
external device like an iPhone or an
iPad to pick up external sounds so for
example if you're having a conversation
with someone in a noisy place the idea
is that you can use your phone put it on
the table and direct the mic from your
phone towards that person and the phone
will pick up the sound it'll be filtered
through a program and you'll hear it
through your air pods and through that
it's supposed to be able to filter out
kind of background noise so you can hear
that sound that you're trying to amplify
better and what the study found was that
airpods Pro using this live listen
function was almost as good as two
different kinds of hearing aids at
helping people with mild to moderate
hearing loss to hear speech better and
also in lab tests it was pretty
comparable as some hearing assist of
devices so airpod Pros aren't actually
hearing aids but there were some
features that made them useful for
people with hearing loss what were those
as you said they're not hearing aids and
actually in the study the co-authors
made it really clear that they tested
airpods not as hearing aids but compared
them to something called the personal
sound amplification product or psaps
which is another type of hearing
assistive technology that it's similar
to hearing aids and that their personal
wearables that help amplify sound but
they're not quite as advanced as hearing
aids but the study found that airpod Pro
was able to function as well as other
peace apps the airpod pro was really
good at making the world louder and
therefore helping some people with
hearing loss to hear better
so have less of our grandparents saying
you know speak up young person maybe
that's what the airpods can do right
exactly
are there limitations to using airpods
if you're trying to compensate for some
of your hearing loss yes definitely the
hearing loss experts I've spoken to and
also the study authors themselves make
it really clear that airpods aren't
going to work for everyone who has
hearing loss it's really only going to
be good for people with certain kinds of
hearing loss and also people with more
mild hearing loss also airpods you know
have limited battery life and so they'll
only last for a few hours at a time
before needing to be recharged so you
know it's not something that you can
wear all day also because of how the
airpod pros work and how they work to
amplify an external sound is you need
another device to pick up those external
sounds so for example if you're having a
conversation with someone and you want
to hear them better you'll have to take
your phone out and direct the microphone
towards that person and so that might be
kind of inconvenient when you're walking
around the world and wanting to hear the
world but better or wanting to hear you
know conversations or maybe someone
approaching from behind you or hear a
car coming or something like that you
need to have your phone out at all times
trying to pick up all this sound and
that can be maybe a bit challenging I
want to broaden this out a little bit
because this summer The Food and Drug
Administration did approve some hearing
aids to be sold over the counter what
has that meant for the broader hearing
aid Market yeah I mean it sounds like
that decision by the FDA has been a real
game changer for the market hearing aids
in general are quite expensive they can
cost several thousand dollars they are
not usually covered by insurance
and so it's quite inaccessible to a lot
of people and in fact the FDA has said
that for people under the age of 69 the
number of people who could benefit from
hearing aids only a tiny fraction of
them actually use hearing aids even
though they would benefit from them and
so the decision by the FDA to allow for
over-the-counter sale of some hearing
aids for adults specifically it seems
like this is going to really spur
Innovation and prompt more investment in
this space it's also already allowed for
cheaper hearing aids to enter the market
the White House said recently that there
are several options now available at
Major pharmacies and other retailers who
are selling hearing aids that cost under
a thousand dollars in some cases under
eight hundred dollars which is a lot
more affordable than was available in
the past for Apple what will this study
mean for them yeah it's interesting I
mean Apple has definitely been getting
more into the healthcare space and it
seems like over the last few years
they've definitely made an effort to
roll out more accessibility functions
the hearing loss experts I've been
speaking to they're very excited about
what companies like apple could do to
really bring exciting new better
products into for instance the hearing
aid space so I guess we'll just have to
see whether or not a study like this
will
compel Apple to put more resources into
this space all right that's our reporter
Dominique mossbergen thanks so much for
joining us Dominique thanks Harry and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
if you want more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
[Music]